[Music]
the resident evil video game series has
been thrilling horror fans around the
globe for over 25 years there's also a
film series starring milovich although
it tends to be avoided by hardcore fans
due to its high action and lower horror
content however the upcoming reboot
resident evil welcome to raccoon city is
meant to address precisely this target
group as the remake deliberately goes in
a considerably creepier direction this
is already proven by the first images
which show three exclusive scenes from
the film among others you can see kyo
scodelario as claire radfield tom hopper
ass albert wesker nathan dales as brett
vickers
hannah john cayman as jill valentine
marina mazepa as lisa trevor and last
but not least robbie amala's chris
radfield the hub of the events will of
course be the infamous spencer mansion
which already terrified fans back in the
first video game particularly the
appearance of lisa trevor costaster
within the fan community after all the
girl who is only 14 years old is the
terrifying result of a failed umbrella
experiment her presence is also a good
sign for it means that the setting of
the original is being adhered to the
reboot resident evil welcome to raccoon
city will be released in theaters on
november 24 2021
[Music]
you